Party leaders are still debating raising
the debt ceiling as the deadline to
default gets closer
but they do agree on one thing
defaulting on our debt is not an option
not an option
it will have catastrophic consequences
they're not exaggerating the U.S
treasury uses tax revenue and debt to
pay the country's bills like funding
government programs Social Security and
pain interest on existing debt if it
runs out of money and isn't able to pay
these investors back that's default and
that's what will happen if Congress
doesn't raise the debt ceiling to allow
the treasury to take on more debt which
would cause massive upheaval and
financial markets stock price is falling
interest rates Rising probably the
dollar falling too and that could affect
a wide range of your own Financial life
in a worst case scenario it could cause
a whole new recession
because U.S debt has become the core of
the economy from Wall Street to Banks to
interest rates U.S treasury borrowing is
the center of gravity for almost all
Finance on the globe here's why how it
works and what a default would mean for
you
this is what the U.S debt is made out of
bonds well technically they could also
be a bill or a note but for our purposes
we're going to call them all bonds and
they're not just how the federal
government takes out debt bonds can be
given out by cities Banks corporations
because a bond is basically an IOU an
investor buys say a thousand dollar Bond
the government or business pays them
interest on it in installments and at
the end of the term their thousand
dollars back
and that amount of interest is based on
how risky that Bond seems to investors
companies that have a long history of
paying their debts say Microsoft pay a
lower interest to bondholders the bank
Credit Suisse paid nearly 10 percent on
some riskier bonds before those were
wiped out when the collapsing Bank was
taken over the higher the risk the
higher the reward investors are always
calculating what's the extra return I
want for the extra risk I'm taking a lot
of investors will ask what is the return
I would get if there was no risk at all
and their answer to that question has
always been to look at the U.S treasury
bond the U.S treasury is seen as the
safest and soundest borrower on planet
Earth which is why it's considered a
benchmark for all Investments a
benchmark is really the base off of
which a lot of other borrowing is done A
lender will want to have something
larger than that Benchmark that's
considered to be the lowest possible
rate if the U.S treasury is issuing at
four percent then corporate bonds or
mortgage bonds or other governments
might issue it five percent or six
percent you can see that Benchmark
treasury rate here in this chart now
here's the 30-year mortgage rate
here's a grouping of Triple A rated
considered the safest corporate bonds
they go up and down in relation to the
U.S debt which is always the lowest The
Benchmark it's kind of like the sun
everything revolves around that
Benchmark that U.S treasury rate
it's more than just the rate of the bond
it's the bonds themselves that are so
Central Wall Street firms Banks
companies a lot of financial
institutions keep money in U.S treasury
bonds it's just always expected that the
U.S treasury is going to make good on
its debt
bonds could be affected two ways by this
debt ceiling debate a contentious fight
could make investors worry they may not
get their money back on time and as a
result they would most likely demand a
higher interest rate for their risk the
same could happen if the big three
credit rating firms have the same fear
and downgrade the U.S AAA credit rating
it's happened before standard and Poor's
did that in 2011 citing the fight around
the debt ceiling but they were the only
ones and it didn't have much of an
effect back then
the worst case scenario is if Congress
doesn't raise the debt ceiling and the
U.S is unable to pay investors on time
and actually defaults
then U.S bonds The Benchmark would be
proven unsafe Investments
if the value of the bonds go down these
Financial portfolios would too
investors would demand higher interest
rates for their higher risk and that
would raise interest rates for everyone
it's kind of like being hit by a meteor
when you don't have confidence that The
Benchmark itself is going to be paid off
it creates uncertainty in financial
markets when there's Financial chaos
very often companies lay people off so
everybody has a stake in this an
analysis by Moody's looked at the
different scenarios if the default is
brief and the treasury prioritizes
paying investors but not say senior
social security the already fragile
economy would have a mild recession with
close to a million jobs lost if the
default goes on for weeks and investors
aren't paid the economic downturn would
be comparable to 2008 costing more than
7 million jobs and wiping out 10
trillion dollars in household wealth
to avoid both scenarios the house senate
and White House must agree to raise the
debt ceiling before the June 1st
deadline many experts call it a game of
chicken but a game where we all lose if
they don't raise it before the clock
Runs Out
foreign